oh yeah Elon Musk I was talking about
earlier talking about moving Tesla out
of California following extended
shelter-in-place
rules local California officials refused
to let Tesla reopen its Fremont factory
Tesla has filed a lawsuit against
Alameda County Elon Musk threatened to
move Tesla's headquarters to Texas or
Nevada where shelter-in-place rules are
less restrictive Elon Musk tweeted the
unelected and ignorant interim health
officer of Alameda is acting contrary to
the governor the president and our
constitutional freedoms and just plain
common sense he said frankly this is the
final straw Tesla is the last car maker
left in California I think you're gonna
run into stuff like this because you
know business owners business operators
they want to they want a business
business people want a business and they
we live in a free market where people
can business and so when a government
comes in at a certain point says aw you
can't business you know I think you're
gonna get you this is what you're gonna
get you're gonna get people to say
that's fine I'm gonna go to a state that
is a little bit more along the lines
with the way that I want to do business
and I say more power to that you know
I'm all for a little bit more for state
governments you know I'd love to see
more you know this is this state and
this is the way that they like to do
things because we're such a we're such a
people that you know people have so many
ideas now and everybody has a platform
now to share their ideas and how they
think and what they like that I feel
like there that there should be almost
more option more options I wish that
everybody were just we are America but
that doesn't seem to be the way that it
is anymore and so I think
if you have a bunch of different kind of
smaller types of America within states
then people can say okay this state is
more to my liking this is where I want
to do my business this is more what I'm
in line with and I think you're gonna
get that you know especially California
in California you know it's very liberal
and you know they try to kind of cater
to you know always help the lowest
common denominator or give everybody you
know they want to help everyone and I
love it I love it in theory but
sometimes in practicality it's not
always you know I don't feel like
there's a lot of you also need to help
yourself whereas some states I feel like
there's a bit more in the constituents
or a customer in their in their in the
ball bag of each of that state that says
earn the Aubry's that says hey you know
we'll help you you also have to help
yourself you also need to do things for
yourself so yeah I think it's neat that
there's if that if any business want to
go with it and then they have the
ability to do that but I'm not surprised
you know I'm not surprised it's
interesting too because in in California
a lot of businesses are so you know
people are very there's a strong sense
of okay everyone needs to wear a mask
our stronger sense here than there are
in other places that I've been and I'm
living mostly in the Hollywood area so
but I see I hear a strong sense of okay
we need to wear masks you have your mask
on want to have your mask on but now
some businesses aren't gonna be able to
come back because they're not going to
be able to make enough money like a
restaurant you know in a neighborhood
where it costs them you know $20,000 a
month for their rent now if they have to
keep tables six feet apart or whatever
they're not going to be able to survive
because
have enough tables in their restaurant
so it's just like you have places that
it's almost like their own extremely or
their own more liberal rules are now
eating up their own businesses if that
makes any sense and sometimes I don't
know what I'm talking about and I always
don't know what I'm talking about um but
but it's like okay well these are this
is the way it needs to be we need to
follow all these guidelines and now the
guidelines have it so they can't even
run their own businesses anymore whereas
you have other places you know I was in
Utah last week and they're just like hey
let's rock
you know let's rock so that's America
though people can you can do it
different ways but businesses are also
going to be able to decide okay I want
to do my business in the place where
they're a little bit more or less rock
or a little or they're a little bit more
no we can't rock because these are the
rules and both of those are okay good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one